never had the immersion of a movie be
ruined by an awful special effect you're
not alone whether they feature outdated
practical effects or uncanny CGI these
sci-fi flicks don't always look their
best
The Matrix won four Academy Awards
including one for best visual effects
even decades later its signature bullet
time looks otherworldly as Neo Dodges
shots in a way perfectly befitting the
film's artificial reality the film's
first sequel 2003's Matrix Reloaded had
a budget of about 150 million dollars
and promised effects that were even
better and it includes a freeway Chase
sequence that certainly clears that bar
on the other hand another scene that
features Neo fighting dozens of clones
of his Nemesis agent Smith in a
courtyard is disappointing officially
dubbed the Burly brawl the set piece
required hundreds of takes a day and a
250 000 square foot Hangar with martial
artists performance stunt work that were
transformed into various smiths in
postal production Reeve certifies
gravity while leaping spinning and
running still looks and moves like a
human throughout the Smiths on the other
hand are formidable at first but they
soon dissolve into a blur of identical
suits and ties
go ahead shoot the best thing about
being me
there's so many me I am Legend the 2007
adaptation of Richard Matheson's iconic
1954 novel is a kind of film that has an
excellent act one in act 2. the fans of
the Will Smith vehicle tend to give the
theatrical ending a pass the scientist
Robert Neville navigates a desolate New
York City following a deadly pandemic
the film was a poignant depiction of
loneliness but whenever Neville crosses
passed with one of the infected and
mutated humans that have been left
behind the film veers into punched up
Action Territory but creatures whose
malleable Jaws hang low and why
bettering creature and production
designer Patrick tatopoulos who's known
for his work on underworld pitch black
and dark city came up with the overall
look of the monsters and they're pretty
scary as long as they're standing
perfectly still the creature's unnatural
jaws and physicality became jarring
during the climax when the infected
alpha male hollers and smashes himself
into the glass to Mark the 20th
anniversary of the Star Wars saga in
1997 lucasfilm released special editions
of the original trilogy with various
changes these included a number of
digital additions to the classic that
started it all such as new dialogue new
backgrounds CGI aliens and Stormtroopers
and revived scenes that were cut from
the original the most infamous of the
re-edited and re-added moments is a
meeting between Han Solo and Jabba the
Hutt the latter of whom was originally
portrayed by the Irish actor Declan
Mulholland in a very best though a
humanoid version of Jabba appeared in
the tie-in comics for the original
series he never actually showed up on
screen no one seemed to mind when he
ended up being a gargantuan slug in
Return of the Jedi unfortunately Creator
George Lucas's idea to insert the
slug-like Jabba over mulholland's
performance in the 20th anniversary
edition is memorable in the worst way
Ford looks fine still won't capture it
in the visual quality of 1977 but the
digitally crisp Jabba seems like he
slithered in from an entirely different
film
Java your wonderful human being it might
not be Mila jovovich's most famous or
best sci-fi classic but ultraviolet has
become a cult favorite over the years
popular among its fans for its
gloriously over the top and downright
ridiculous cyberpunk action the film
stars Jovovich a superhero Violet song
in a dystopian future ravaged by disease
she embarks on a mission to protect a
boy whose blood May hold the Cure Ultra
violent and Ultra colorful the effects
throughout the movie are substandard at
best but one notorious sequence is Head
and Shoulders Above the Rest when it
comes to its awfulness after Violet
leaps off a building cuts down a group
of gun toting mercs and proceeds to race
through the city on her motorcycle large
parts of the chase sequence appear
composited using sloppy blue screen
effects intercut with embarrassing CGI
awkward Direction doesn't help and the
result is laughable even by the
standards of a Saturday morning cartoon
virtual reality has been majorly refined
in recent years but it wasn't nearly as
advanced when the lawnmower man debuted
in 1992. still the concept of a virtual
world was a popular idea that made for
plenty of intriguing stories in the 90s
based on a Stephen King's Story and name
only the lawnmower man is a cautionary
tale about a scientist who introduces a
developmentally disabled man named job
to Virtual Technology unfortunately
because of a low budget or lack of
imagination or maybe both the virtual
world depicted here turns out to be a
pretty dull array of geometric mosaics
reminiscent of a Windows 95 screensaver
once job's mind expands and merges with
the machine the digital rendering of his
character complete with wonky eyes that
look pasted in from a different
illustration ends up squarely on the
wrong side of The Uncanny Valley you're
a freak you're naive
to make a great modern superhero
Blockbuster first class visual effects
are crucial some of the best comic book
films have done it right with a number
of Marvel movies having been nominated
for best visual effects at the Academy
Awards despite its historic nomination
for best picture though black panther
wasn't one of them the 2018 Blockbuster
had some questionable moments that Drew
plenty of criticism particularly in its
final battle one moment that stands out
to fans is the climactic showdown
between t'challa and his rival Eric
killmonger and the wakandan vibranian
mine Boulder clad entirely and CGI
created Cat inspired super suits facing
off an entirely CGI environment the
effect is unremarkable at best and
actively irritating at worst and his
review for n Gadget writer Devendra
harderwar wrote of the film black
panther is a refreshing answer to the
increasingly stale world of superhero
Cinema but there's one glaring flaw
throughout the film its use of CG models
to replace humans during action
sequences their weightless ugly and
worst of all incredibly distracting
writer director Andrew Nichol is
responsible for creative and clever
films like 1997's Gattaca 1998's The
Truman Show so with venerable
cinematographer Roger deakins on his
team 2011's in time held a lot of
Promise the plot is a Twist of the 1970s
sci-fi favorite Logan's Run set in
future where time is literally money in
this dystopian Universe people don't
live past 25 unless it can earn or steal
additional days months and years
unfortunately though the cool concept is
mostly wasted on time puns you need to
get out of here
somebody's gonna clean that clock yes it
seems that the filmmakers must have run
out of time to stage one particular
stunt or flesh out a convincing visual
effect after Justin Timberlake and
Amanda Cypher had find themselves on the
run the couple Koreans off the road in a
convertible during an unintentionally
hilarious moment for a second the
flipping car looks like a Hot Wheels toy
and it magically lands upright too
Superman the movie is often credited for
kicking off the superhero movie boom as
it was the first truly big budget
adaptation of a comic book hero to
capture the world's imagination a large
part of that was its stunning visual
effects which well not exactly
revolutionary did just enough to make
the last son of Krypton believable as a
dramatic character rather than a
children's cartoon while the film boasts
some impressive flying effects and some
nice action sequences that looked great
on the big screen especially by 1978
standards there's one big moment that
doesn't pass muster it happens when Lex
Luthor fires a series of missiles in an
effort to disturb the San Andreas fault
and sink the California coast into the
sea resulting destruction is captured
with the use of a miniature set that
just looks plain bad it's an effect that
leaves a lot to be desired between the
Tiny Town the obvious model trains and
the stream of water that's clearly not
much more than a bucket's worth the
whole sequence is not convincing in the
least
despite the growing popularity of all
things superhero in 2011 most people
didn't seem to find Ryan Reynolds take
on Green Lantern worth their time
Reynolds himself would probably tell you
that the decision to digitize how
Jordan's uniform was the nail in the
coffin as he's joked about in his
Deadpool movies
and please don't make the super suit
green
or animated despite the annoying CGI
outfit the arguably greater distraction
especially considering the film's
reported 200 million dollar budget is a
depiction of the villain Parallax voiced
by veteran actor Clancy Brown Parallax
is supposed to be the living embodiment
of fear and the comics Parallax is
depicted as more bug-like or bat-like
but the film's roiling black and yellow
Cloud that spreads over the city in the
climactic battle is more similar to the
foam sealant that snugs around pipes
it's hard to feel like Hal Jordan is in
danger when he's facing off against an
Angry Cloud still Green Lantern did one
thing right it brought together future
spouses Ryan Reynolds and Blake Lively
the original crew of the USS Enterprise
journeyed to the big screen in 1979 Star
Trek the motion picture which was
nominated for the visual effects
category at the Oscars there's a reason
it was beaten out by alien though and
it's not just because the xenomorph
looks so good no the truth is that Star
Trek the motion picture simply doesn't
look all that great even by late 70s
standards the climax looks particularly
peculiar as crew and Decker opts to
merge his mind and body with the Voyager
spacecraft the real Voyager missions
launched in 1977 and involved twin
spacecraft that initially targeted
close-up views of Jupiter and Saturn but
Star Trek imagines Voyager becoming
sentient during its travels and adopting
the name bijer the filming of Star Trek
the motion picture was troubled to say
the least the contentious shoots
included a number of injuries when crew
members fell through the lights panels
and plastic surrounding bijer during the
big scene the end result is rather meh
but Decker appearing backlit while his
hair blows and sparkly lights Cascade
around him in 1980 Flash Gordon adapted
the classic 1930s comic strips in search
of movie Magic and although the end
result is spectacularly cheesy it still
inspires plenty of affection the costume
and production design from Bath to
nominee the nilo Donati is truly
exceptional using retro Kitsch among all
that red and gold the effects team
deserves heaps of kudos for
inventiveness creating memorable images
like Planet Mongo's multi-colored clouds
elaborate starships and winged Hawkman
unfortunately the demise of the
merciless emperor Ming played by the
legendary Max von Sito Bears worse a
wounded Ming holds flash at Bay with his
ring which pulsates with red magic light
my life
is not for any Earthling to give
or take after his ironic final words the
ring zaps its wearer dissolving the
merciless leader out of reality it's a
cathartic moment for sure and that
doesn't make it any more convincing even
Star Wars a franchise known for pushing
the boundaries of visual effects doesn't
always get it right in 2016 the newly
relaunched franchise came roaring into
theaters with its first ever Standalone
film Rogue one a Star Wars story which
explored the untold tale behind the
rebel alliance's Heist of the Death Star
plans in addition to introducing a host
of new and exciting heroes and villains
it also brought back a few old faces one
of those faces belongs to Grandma turken
a key villain from the original Star
Wars film in 1977. the problem of course
was that the actor who originally played
him Peter Cushing died in 1994 rather
than simply cast a new actor to play in
the visual effects Wizards at industrial
Light and Magic tried to resurrect him
through CGI using motion capture
performed by Cushing impersonator guy
Henry augmented with state of the
artifacts they brought Tarkin back to
life but it wasn't quite convincing for
many looking acceptable in Shadow and
sometimes adequate when motionless the
CGI created Tarkin Falls deeper into The
Uncanny Valley the longer he's on screen
some moments even make him feel more
like a character from The Animated Clone
Wars TV series to this day Paul
verhoven's RoboCop remains a seminal
classic of 80s sci-fi a dystopian story
that elevated the genre with its
high-tech Hero full of stinging social
satire the film is also packed with
wall-to-wall graphic violence as the
cyborg cop blows away baddies with
little Mercy Beyond just plugging
low-life crooks on the streets of
Detroit though the RoboCop also dealt
with corporate and government corruption
despite Kirkwood Smith's excellent turn
as Clarence boedeker the film's True
Villain is his boss dick Jones senior
president of ocp the company responsible
for RoboCop when Jones finally gets what
he deserves though it's a pretty big
letdown both literally and figuratively
the iconic scene ends with Robocop
shooting Jones repeatedly letting loose
a barrage of bullets that push him out a
high-rise window to his death
dick you're fine
thank you
when the camera cuts to his hundred
story fall to the ground what the
audience gets is an obvious dummy with
arms that look comically long luckily
the rest of Robocop is such a campy good
time that most people are able to look
past it between Star Trek and Star Wars
the latter has always had the reputation
for the bigger and better special
effects after all early Star Trek is
Infamous for its often cheap looking
effects on the small screen in the 1960s
therefore it might surprise some to
learn that it was actually George
Lucas's industrial Light and Magic that
created many of the visual effects for
the Star Trek feature films including
the early use of CGI in Star Trek 2 the
Wrath of Khan sadly ilm was not involved
in making of Star Trek insurrection the
third film of the Next Generation era
and it shows and one climactic sequence
of Ellen ruapo subjects a crooked
Federation Admiral Doherty to the same
procedure that he'd been using to keep
his own aging flesh fresh he peels back
the skin of the poor Starfleet sucker
and let's just say that the effect isn't
up to the standards of a Blockbuster I5
franchise looking more like a haphazard
swipe on a Photoshop smudge tool the
effect appears like a last minute rush
job by the VFX team as they ran out of
time and money one of the most
disappointing sequels in sci-fi history
escape from La reunited Escape From New
York star Kurt Russell with original
director John Carpenter it's become a
cult classic for all the wrong reasons
fans were probably expecting another
iconic action movie so it couldn't have
been pleasant when what they saw was an
incoherent mess released in 1996 more
than a decade after the original escape
from La simply lacked the originality
and freshness of its predecessor while
the first movie's special effects were
never anything groundbreaking the
sequels are downright goofy case in
points is one now legendary tsunami
surfing scene when Russell snake fliskin
befriends a Malibu Surfer played by
Hollywood Legend Peter Fonda the pair
ride a giant wave through the Canyons of
post-apocalyptic Los Angeles but from
the very first moment the water comes
into view the visual effects are an
unmitigated travesty there's bad chroma
Keen as the flood overtakes a dune buggy
and inducing blue screen usage that
never convinces you that the duo are
surfing rather than just awkwardly
swaying while standing still as I ride
the way the movie's villain played by
the incomparable Steve Buscemi Echoes
the thoughts of everyone watching
before Hollywood was attempting to
create CGI people from scratch it tried
its hand at Virtual de-aging Technology
after a few awkward attempts in the
X-Men movies Disney gave it a shot in
the legacy sequel to the 1982 cult
classic Tron directed by Joseph Kosinski
and released in 2010 Tron legacy saw
original Star jet Bridges return as
Kevin Flynn the computer programmer
trapped in a digital world is ultimately
rescued by his now adult son Sam and in
both flashbacks and inside the virtual
realm de-aging was used to make the then
61 year old bridges look decades younger
unfortunately the final results weren't
exactly convincing the younger Bridges
both as a 30-something plan and as is
digital double clue looks like a
character from a video game cutscene
granted digital daging still hasn't been
perfected and it's since been used to
better effect in later movies like the
Irishman and Indiana Jones and the dial
of Destiny thankfully the other visual
effects alongside Daft Punk's
Unforgettable soundtrack make Tron
legacy a worthwhile watch regardless
decades before Netflix made their own
take on the Swiss Family Robin in an
outer space for three seasons new line
Cinema launched a 1998 remake of the
popular 1965 TV series Lost in Space
with an All-Star cast including Gary
Oldman William Hurt Mimi Rogers Heather
Graham Lacey Chabert and Matt LeBlanc it
seemed like a Surefire hit set in 2058
the film sends a Robinson company to
colonize a new planet after Earth
suffers the crippling effects of climate
change unfortunately the esteemed actors
are forced to share screen time with the
CG Critter named dwarf who's supposed to
be a kind of extraterrestrial monkey the
filmmaker shot blarp with an animatronic
puppet that remained in close-up shots
but the special effects Department under
supervisor Nick Alder of alien in The
Fifth Element Fame went digital in
post-production the result is a creature
that's not really there as the actors
obviously aren't interacting with
anything in the same scene and have no
idea where to look
we're both film
I'm home
apparently little one
a bad effect in the 1986 classic aliens
may seem like an impossibility to some
there aren't many faults to be had with
James Cameron's iconic sequel which
turned the previous film's creepy horror
story into a fast-paced run and Gun
space action epic the special effects in
aliens are as good if not better than
anything else seen in cinemas at the
time and they contribute to the film's
continued impact however there's one
sloppy effect that once you see it is
impossible to miss when the Android
Bishop is torn in half by the alien
queen it looks nice and creepy at first
but once actor Lance Henriksen hits the
ground it's pretty obvious that his legs
have been hidden in the floor as sloppy
goop and oatmeal are poured all over him
at the same time Henrik sends total
immobility also breaks the illusion as
many eagle-eyed fans have since noticed
when he does have to move to save nuke
from the vacuum of space the hole in the
set where Henriksen is standing becomes
briefly visible sadly the suspension of
disbelief that Cameron and his crew
worked so hard on to establish is broken
in this one moment
James Cameron is famous for his first
rate special effects and here we are
accusing two of his films of lacking in
that department it might sound hard to
believe but we're making the case that
there's one moment in the groundbreaking
classic the Terminator that qualifies it
for a spot on this list now it's not any
of Stan Winston's brilliant work on the
T800 endoskeleton expertly brought to
life during the final battle with Sarah
O'Connor at the end of the film instead
it comes in a disturbing sequence in
which the Terminator was forced to
repair his own eye the effect of the
Terminator cutting out his own eyeball
is definitely an effective moment that
makes audiences squirm with discomfort
for the after effects when the
Terminator tends to his empty socket and
looks at himself in the mirror just
doesn't hold up to basic scrutiny while
it was state-of-the-art puppet work for
its time it's unrealistic and almost
unrecognizable as the doppelganger of
Arnold Schwarzenegger the full reveal of
the latex and rubber dummy head with an
obvious wig threatens to ruin the entire
sequence when it's over quickly enough
that it's easy to move past
The Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy
started out as a hilarious series of
novels by Douglas Adams which were
turned into a BBC television series in
the early 1980s decades later in 2005
Every Man Arthur Dent made his way to
the big screen when he was portrayed by
Future Sherlock star Martin Freeman dent
in ordinary Englishman finds himself
swept up in an Interstellar Adventure
After Earth is demolished to make way
for an Interstellar Expressway alongside
earthgirl trillian and alien guideboard
prefect Dent meets the president of the
Galaxy the two-headed three-armed zapod
beeblebrox played by Sam Rockwell hey
Xavier
what's with the two head thing
oh yeah
apparently you can't be president with
the whole brain that's crazy
Hitchhiker's Guide boasts some truly
creative visuals and incredible
practical alien effects but the CGI used
to bring zapod's double Noggins to life
is sorely lacking in an effort to avoid
having to give zapod two heads at all
times his second face is often hidden
beneath his collar under his chin and
although it only pops up on occasion the
effect is unarguably awkward fans have
come to affectionately refer to it as
the Pez dispenser and while the CGI
isn't entirely awful it's not really
that convincing either that said it
still beats a fake rubber head on a
stick which is how they did it on
television back in the 1980s digital D
aging and sci-fi can backfire badly but
bad old age makeup can have the same
effect the most astonishing example
might just be in Ridley Scott's
Prometheus the long-awaited prequel to
the 1979 classic alien here Weyland
yatani founder Peter Weyland is
portrayed as an elderly man on a
lifelong quest for the answers to Life's
greatest questions for some reason
though Scott casts the then 44 year old
actor Guy Pierce to play the 104 year
old billionaire old age effects had
already been done successfully for
decades pulled off brilliantly with
makeup in movies like Citizen Kane and
The Godfather and by a CGI and The
Curious Case of Benjamin Button for some
reason the Prosthetics and makeup
effects used on Piers never seem to work
making him look like some kind of
cartoon character instead funnily enough
the only reason Pierce was even cast was
that early versions of the story
included flashbacks to a younger Wayland
but those scenes were cut from the film
George Lucas wasn't the only director to
use Advanced computer-generated special
effects to overhaul one of his older
classic masterpieces in the wake of the
Star Wars special edition re-releases
Steven Spielberg decided to give his
1982 sci-fi family film E.T the
Extraterrestrial a digital facelift in
honor of its 20th anniversary this
included using CGI to spruce up existing
practical effects finish incomplete
deleted scenes for newly included
moments and even to redo old scenes that
he was no longer fond of the most famous
change made is the Erasure of all guns
from the scene where the police try to
apprehend little Elliot in E.T replacing
them with CGI walkie-talkies though it
was considered fine in 1982 by 2002
Spielberg felt that having guns in a
kid's movie wasn't entirely appropriate
the replacement is awkwardly executed to
the point of looking silly making the
movie less impactful as a whole
foreign
[Music]
that's not all as a deleted scene that
sees E.T taking a bath is finished with
CGI that looks woefully out of place in
a movie notable for its quality
practical effects in 2023 though the
director admitted that the CGI editions
were a mistake
[Music]